bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale la
leçon émission spéciale défense
sicilienne
la sicilienne l'âge d'or le coût 6 x 3
avec stéphane laborde bonjour stéphane
bonjour et loi ce coup ci se fout de
troyes a été joué par gary kasparov a
été jouée par tous les grands joueurs de
sylviane avec les blancs tous les grands
joueurs de 2,4 c'est l'une des banques
les plus dangereuses c'est une erreur
n'at elle plus dangereuse aussi les plus
compliqués les blancs veulent très vite
l'ancien nassau d'options aller loin
avec f3 et j'ai 4 et le fouet trois
lorgne notamment dans la classe b 6 où
va s'installer un cavalier noir
c'est évidemment un plan d' attaque
régulièrement jouer avec des rocs opposé
donc la cdp reliant tous les blancs font
le grand roque c'est une sorte d'
attaque anglaise c'est la formation h f
3 et 4 ans vous commentera tout à
l'heure donc cette ouverture stéphane
est très très dangereuse il faut
connaître précisément c'est ce qu'on va
montrer aujourd'hui c'est dangereux pour
les deux camps c'est dangereux pour les
deux camps puisqu'on sait que le
meilleur joueur gagne dans cette
position puisque gary kasparov qui les
blancs et les noirs gagne et on gagne à
chaque fois il ya chaque fois avec les
de couleur or et savoir ce qu'il ferait
si jouer contre lui même exactement donc
capable de gagner deux fois avec les
blanc et noirs il n'ya que rambo qui
peut battre en beauce est bien connue
donc que nous allons tout de suite vous
montrer les coûts de cette ouverture
s'il faut 3 une des variantes les plus
dangereuses prochaine entre le nashor
donc échiquier et c'est parti
eux quatre ces cinq cavaliers f3 des six
des caps sicile et nous verte
donc ouais j'en prends des quatre caves
il prend des quatre le coût normal
qu'avec et fiscales ya six ans les
blancs répondent par kbc 3 maintenant à
six la nage d'or nous sommes en plein
dedans
hélas le coup f3 stéphane on se rappelle
que la dernière fois nous avions vu le
système de scheveningen qui est un peu
différent on est tout à fait puisque les
blancs ne joue pas avec f3 mais ils
jouent tout simplement fou et deux dans
cette position et ensuite avec petit
rock foo étroit et f4 donc là vous
pouvez regarder dans les archives de
diagonale l'émission sur le système de
chef d'un gang et vous trouverez donc
exactement cette position ici le coup et
6 f3 ou s'il faut ou trois c'est une
inversion coup l'idée ça évite des
souverainetés f3 parce que sur fouet
trois les noirs peuvent quand même joué
cavalier g4 directement qui rentre dans
une variante un peu différente
on montrera tout à l'heure les quelques
subtilités
il ya également des inconvénients
notamment ici les noirs peuvent par
exemple joué le 5 mai pour généraliser
tout ça qu'il joue au 6e coup donc dans
cette position présente le coup f3 ou le
couffo 3 nous répondrons pareil nous
jouerons le coup à 6 2-6 donc qu'il a
dit tout de suite la structure du petit
sans être très souple
maintenant cette forêt 3 à l'orienter
aussi quant à eux trois le fou va pas
gêner l'avancé des pions blancs c'est à
dire qu'on va jouer g4 g5
évidemment si on a déjoué fou g5 se
serait pas possible donc tout de suite
des blancs la première remarque stéphane
ils vont a priori faire le gros rock ou
pour pouvoir pousser lors d'options h2g2
tels des béliers qui vont donc pulvérisé
la position du roi noir qui normalement
lui warocqué du petit côté oui alors
c'est là justement une des premières
règles dans cette ouverture
on n'est pas pressé de roque et il faut
il absolument pas donner l'adresse de
son roi la relève sinon certains à part
ok c'est sûr que l'homme l'a poussée de
ses pions blancs vont enfin peu dans le
vide elle est dangereuse quand même
puisque effectivement l'idée des blancs
c'est d'arriver à jouer j'ai 5 h 5
et dans cette question jouer g6 un coût
qui sera dévastateur sur les cases
blanches notamment de son v6 qui sera
faible
le pion à vii et tout ça c'est quand
même autour de la position du roi n'aura
il n'est jamais question pratiquement
pour les noirs de jury prend rock
il faut donc laisser l'europe centre est
très vite la seule chose à faire quand
on est attaqué stéphane c'était de
contre attaque dont ses deux
contre-attaqués donc directement des
cinq mois la b5 à noter que les blancs
on n'aurait pas pu jouer à 4 pour un
pichet b5 puisque dans ce cas là s'ils
jouent à quatre ils affaiblissent leur
propre groupe
exactement donc s'il joue avec à 4 les
blancs ne peuvent plus jouer grand roque
et tout de suite qu'ils peuvent pas
jouer les crocs
il devient très délicat de pousser le
pion en g4 mais c'est normal puisque le
roi blanc va quand même se retrouver
affaiblie
ici deux coups possibles la dame en d2
où le coup j'ai 4 donc ça c'est les deux
possibilités on va tout de suite regardé
le coup j'ai 4 donc c'est une partie
gritche août contre garry kasparov qui
était jouée à la coupe du monde de cam
ou donc partie de référence évidemment
gré tous très bien préparé c'est un
tueur de sicilienne garry kasparov s'est
le plus fervent défenseur de cette
défense sicilienne donc ici g4 est joué
l'idée c'est d'éviter
certaines variantes mais de toute façon
ça change pas grand chose ici les noirs
vont organiser leurs deux cavaliers donc
c'est très curieux parce que stéphane
comme on le sait il faut pas jouer deux
fois avec les mêmes pièces en ouverture
oui alors là disons qu'ils se posent un
problème on noircit le développement du
cavalier b8 c'est à dire si ce cavalier
des huit ne peut pas venir en c6 puisque
le cahier des quatre contrôles et sylvia
sur la case 17
eh bien ils enlèvent une case à l'autre
cavaliers donc en poussant g5 on
poussera ce cavalier à la bande
exactement règle donc une des règles
principales
quand vous êtes dans ce genre de
position et bien ce cavalier m6 ne doit
jamais partir sur la case h5 maison qui
serait pas très efficace quand il serait
mal placé il serait super si susceptible
pardon d'être attaqué donc il faut
absolument pas le mettre là ce qu'avait
dit m6 toujours retard sur la tête des
sept puisque évidemment il va partir les
blancs vont jouer g5 ça c'est évident
ici donc il faut replacer les deux
cavaliers le caire et des beats et
cavaliers this on n'est pas pressé de
bouger le foie fuite
encore une règle dans cette ouverture
ces femmes puisque je me fous et flûte
en os est ça apporte pas grand chose
sachant que les noirs n'ont pas une
envie particulière de roque et ouais
parce que pour l'instant les pionniers
les pions blancs sont quand même
menaçant les pions blancs sont menaçants
donc dans cette position mais comme tu
l'as dit on ne joue pas qui a et b 17
puisqu'après g5
tout de suite on est me booster il faut
jouer g5 tout de suite parce que sinon
les noirs ont le temps de jouer cavalier
de bessilles oui tout à fait donc ici on
joue cavalier f17 comme ça au moins
notre cavalier ne sera plus attaquer
quand les blanches orangées 5 et les
blancs vont jouer g5 bientôt dam des
deux et si on continue à se réorganiser
en jouant cavalier b6
donc ça c'est on va voir que les deux
cavaliers vont trouver des emplacements
bien particulier ouais c'est très
typique dans cette position le lidec
validé si stéphane c'est pas forcément
de calais ces quatre noms dans certaines
sphères une pièce du côté du grand roque
des blancs donc maintenant le deuxième
cavaliers ou ce qui doit pas être loin
le fouet fuite lorgne quand même sur la
case à 3 et puis manquera plus qu'à
activer le fou s'est vite si on arrive à
l'activé toutes les pièces lorgneront
vers leur grand roc blanc exactement
grand roque ici très logique cavaliers
817 donc toujours ce duo de cavaliers
qui se déploie damev de alors ça c'est
un coup on peut également envisager
stéphane pour les blancs de jouer par
exemple un coup comme h4 ouais donc ça
c'est possible h4 alors maintenant plein
de plein de réactions possibles pour les
noirs notamment donc on a toujours envie
de jouer avec des 5
ça c'est le fameux coup libérateur dans
la défense sicilienne donc ici on peut
tout à fait envisager de jouer
stéphane b 4 way le cavalier doit partir
c'est la casse de 2 par exemple sur
laquelle alors la casse au dos il ya un
gros problème tout de suite c'est le
goût qui est salt et 6 4 qui prend le
foot - mais il n'a pas beaucoup de casse
ce cas mais alors le cavalier doit
plutôt partir sur la classe b un gaz
assez moche ouais
et ici on pourrait jouer je pense à
priori le coup libérateur des six des 5
pourquoi parce que le cas est bien très
mal placé les blancs ont perdu du temps
en jouant jusqu'à peser 4 et donc la
réaction contre une attaque allen
on le dit souvent stéphane noro créons
centre réaction au centre est parfaite
la réaction au centre puisque en cas de
prise
on reprend du cavalier me kane est donc
très fort en dessin qui attaquent le
four 3 et le cavaly b1 des blancs très
mal placé ça c'est tout le problème des
blancs est ici donc effectivement tout
de suite problème le problème bien que
après beckham justement on ne peut pas
jouer cavalier en co2 ou là
effectivement il serait bien plus bien
mieux placé pour riposter contre des 5
puisqu'il serait encore dans l'action on
peut pêcher qui a eu lieu à cause de
caisse et 4 ap on veut donc ici après
huit décès est directement la menace
c'est des quatre dames f2 donc ça c'est
une réaction logique puisque maintenant
sur b4 on va jouer le cavalier sur la
case de deux caisses et 4 ne nous fait
pas peur
ce concert avec la dame fou bessette ça
c'est complètement le plan classique
malencontreux très bien la case des cinq
pour jouer le coup libérateur des six
des 5
à noter que lecavalier en dix-sept
empêche les blancs de fermer la pause
avec nos quatre ou cinq ce qui est
important aussi c'est extrêmement
important quand vous êtes prêt à jouer
dès six dessins qui est un coup
thématique le coup libérateur notamment
du fouet fuite
le coût qui va ouvrir un petit peu la
position au centre si les blancs ont
perdu trop de temps à pousser leurs
pions ça c'est ce qu'il faut voir et
bien à ce moment là le coût des 5
devient extrêmement puissants mais il
faut contre la casse de 5 il faut pas
que les blancs puis se permet en jouant
aux 4 5 fu détroit joué par greg shaw
d'ici là on pourrait jouer dès 4 et
dessins que c'est possible mais kasparov
a vu mieux
il a vu tours s'est vite pour ces huit
dans cette position qui menace le coup
tours s'est vite pour encaisser 3
sacrifice de qualité donc ça perd une
tour contre un cavalier mais les blancs
reprenant à la corruption b2 se retrouve
dans une situation extrêmement délicate
extrêmement délicate
c'est le thème de la partie mof session
contre kasparov qui a été jouée dans un
tournoi qu on vous montrera par la suite
pour concept roi est une menace dans
cette position donc rude choc a joué
comme les ce2 et ensuite
donc là on va s'arrêter très
prochainement on va juste regarder qu'à
et c5 de kasparov
ils menacent de prendre le fou en d3 une
fois que ce fou et prix en dessous des 5
très fort cassant toutes les cases
blanches roi bien maintenant sur la
prise du fou on reprend avec l'option et
on renforce le centre c'est à dire qu on
se prémunit contre dessin qui est en
renforçant notre centre mais maintenant
c'est à dire qu'on pouvait pas avant
puisque le roi était en échec par la
tour c 8 extrême est heureux tout à fait
tout à fait le fiancé de auraient été
floués quelle idée à 4 voilà on voit que
ces deux cavaliers sont menaçants quand
même sont très menaçants très très
menaçants l'idc régulièrement de prendre
en d3 alors amené le deuxième cas
d'inceste et le réflexe a pas à ne pas
avoir cessé de jouer b2 b3 qui a figuré
complètement le rock b3 c'est possible
d'ailleurs stéphane ça a été choisi par
judit polgar way maison que c'est tout à
fait possible des intentions ses
responsables s'est mis à chauffer
responsabilité est profond et cavaliers
deuxième colis en c5
voilà donc ça c'est un premier exemple
de partie mais effectivement l'idée
et c'est pas de vous apprendre à jouer
aussi loin que kasparov et de vous
apprendre à jouer l'ouverture en général
donc là vous avez un très bon exemple
d'une partie menée par kasparov qui
aboutit à une position complexe
extrêmement complexe ici on voit qu'il
ya de la taxe des deux côtés 1 les bleus
ont gardé leur potentiel d'attac
les noirs ont développé le leur mais ici
une chose est sûre vous n'êtes pas
perdant vous n'êtes peut-être même pas
moins bien c'est une position tout à
fait jouable et bien dans l'esprit de la
ccid yens il faut garder à l'idée et on
voit plein en retardant au maximum le
développement de leur fuite et de la
tranche 8
ils attendent de pouvoir jouer des cinq
avant de pouvoir le bouger donc ici au
programme
ces dames c'est 7 puis des 5% contrôler
la classe de ce1 voilà puisque la
d'avancé 7 contrôlera cette case ou 5
d'ailleurs c'est la suite de la partie
on va vous le montrer c'est très
instructif h4 dame ses sept tours c'est
un tour c'est un puisque la menace
s'était prendront des 3 et
éventuellement donc de bien contrôler
cette commune c'est vraiment elle veut
se prémunir contre ça et maintenant des
cinq coups libérateur issygrid tout cas
paniqué il a joué le simple dames 35
gens plus pour garry kasparov et il a
ensuite transformé son nez c'est donc
nous allons tout de suite vous montrer
une nouvelle partie qui est donc la
partie polgar kasparov donc ça c'est en
fait c'est la même chose on va pas
vouloir montrer tout simplement nos
obsessions kasparov très intéressant
également
donc c'est les premiers coups sans lui
même voilà des quatre pions prendre les
quatre cavaliers prendre qu à 1600 kg
soir à 6003 faux et 3 cette fois donc
c'est un peu différent là les noirs
peuvent jouer le coup cavaliers g4 et
qu'il rentre une sous variantes mais
très intéressante il faut que les blancs
répondent pas refuge et 5 et ça devient
très compliqué c'est très compliqué
effectivement notre objectif étant de
vous apprendre à jouer la ccn nash dorff
on ne va pas vous apprendre à jouer
toutes les variantes pour les noirs
puisqu'il suffit d'une seule
il suffit de jouer dans cette position
aussi ce qui est différent de kg cas et
qui les différencie du coût de 7,5 qui
existent également dans cette position
stephen de 6 donc c'est le coût normal
f3 alors là fait un effort pour vous
rappeler ce qu'il faut jouer
qu'est ce qu'on a dit stéphane et bien
il faut contre-attaqué faux contre
attaque est une première étape b5 dans
leur logique dam des deux et là on voit
que les blancs donc pas jouer g4 à la
place de dan d2 et donc de dmd de tout
de suite moi ils n'ont pas encore joué
car il n'y a pas chez celles qui
menacent donc on peut jouer
b 17 voilà ce qui n'est pas pareil
puisque dans la position où tu attends
j'ai dit à tv5
là il n'y a pas chez 5 donc on peut
mettre ce qu'amélie la grand'rue grand
roque
loïc est maintenant sous b cette voie là
fo 17 très logique aussi tant que les
blancs ne menace pas chez 5 on regarde
le camion 17 g4 donc j'ai quatre
maintenant menace g5 qui pousse le
cavalier à bandes
donc c'est le bon moment pour jouer
notre cavalier pour libérer la case des
fêtes exactement
donc on joue qui avait six autres
grandes variantes cb4 avec une masse de
théories gigantesque on va pas vous la
montrer parce qu'elle est trop compliqué
trop compliqué il ya beaucoup de lignes
parker à apprendre et c'est pas
évidemment l'intérêt donc qu'elle
épaississe et l'appareil toujours le
même problème la menace dans cette
position cd4 qui force le cas et c'est 3
à partir sur la thèse bien rappelez vous
bien que une fois qu'il est en bien
c'est le moment on va pouvoir commencer
à envisager des 5 alors là peut-être pas
tout de suite parce que eux scène que
est possible pour les blancs pas tout de
suite pascal au 5 mai que peuvent faire
les blancs dans cette position il pas
grand chose s'il joue acheté à trompeuse
riquet 17 et menacé des 4 et ensuite des
saints donc damev deux dames f2 n'est
qu'une petite menace de judith cavaler
prendre six quais les proxys ce donc là
c'est l'obsession
ouais mais 2h06 puisqu'après la batterie
fouet dame qui n'existait pas avant
on va ramasser le cavalier en b 6
cavaliers le 17
donc protège le cavalier double effet
puisque ça protège le camion plus et
gagnent du temps du temps parce que
quand il aura g5 et bien ça n'attaquera
plus rien une obsession je crois bien
tours s'est vite donc on voit que c'est
à peu près les même coup un toujours
c'est la même position sauf que la
dernière fois il y avait eu ce coup le
cavalier qui revient sur la case de 2
way s'annonce et s était pas ça en fait
la dernière fois les infos ya lui fout
d'être à la place moins bien mais tout à
fait permis qui a laissé venir là donc
il ya une petite faute de mots session
qui ne connaissait pas la partie puisque
celle là et a été joué avant et dans
cette position obsession se retrouve
très ennuyée oui parce que sur cavaillon
oeil à cavalli c4 keller embêtant c'est
ça cavalia 2 le problème c'est que le
fou n'est pas là donc on peut jouer des
cinq mais aussi jeux
je vous descendre qui tout de suite fait
exploser le centre et on voit que les
pièces blanches sont extrêmement mal
placé donc on va envisager ce coût est
ici donc assez cap effectivement
stéphane c'est un bon coup des 5
c'est un autre bon coup on peut montrer
également puisque là et bien tout de
suite on attaque le client peut pas
jouer au saigne toujours très important
sur eux 5
le cavalier prend le sens quoique un peu
décalé prend aussi ça on peut jouer on
peut jouer ou 5 mais enfin c'est assez
c'est assez chaud ça c'est chaud c'est
même très attendu puisqu'il peut y avoir
que ses quatre enfants
ici les noirs - très bon jeu de pièces
c'est ça qu'il faut dire on voit que le
développement des blancs est pas
terrible
la tour ans à charge ou pas le fond afin
est pas encore sorti alors que les noirs
dans deux coups fawcett est petit rock
ils ont sorti toutes leurs pièces est le
centre est ouvert
donc tout simplement équilibre dynamique
personne n'est en avance au niveau du
développement événement ou un meilleur
jeu de pièces le fou bessette est très
fort la tour s'est vite aussi le
canadien b6 peut sauter en c4 ou aller
en d5
bref pleinement son bien après tour
celui de problème donc pour une
obsession qui je fous détroit donc ils
allèrent se dire au bon moment et juste
après je vais jouer cavalier ou deux et
je vais jouer maintenant cava22
tranquille mais la toile pensée 3 et wii
le thématique de thématiques
alors quand même fou quand même avoir
les reins solides pour jouer un
sacrifice aux qualités aussi tôt dans la
partie parce qu'on est qu'au 13e coup
quand même nous sommes au troisième coup
mais ce sacrifice de qualité alors il
est particulier puisqu'en général l'idée
c'est de récupérer ensuite le pion aux 4
c'est à dire qu'on donne une tour pour
éliminer le défenseur du chievo 4 et
ensuite on prend mais si c'est pas du
tout l'idée de garry kasparov puisque ce
pion aux 4 et blindés ouais on voit
qu'il est défendu deux fois
l'idée c'est vraiment stéphane la taxe
sur leurs ouailles affaiblir les cases
noires l'affaiblissement des cases
noires élimination du défenseur
principal qui est autour de groix donc
après plus reprend ses droits
les noirs ne sont pas pressés dans cette
position ils n'ont pas envie de
récupérer tout de suite leur matériel
ils ont simplement ramener toutes leurs
pièces en choses et ensuite tout
simplement les blancs ne pourront pas se
défendre parce que cette structure de
pions et très très difficile à défendre
et la tour de plus la tour contrôle
cavaliers supplémentaires n'êtes pas
dans cette défense mais il y aura
beaucoup de colonne ouverte
on va regarder le défilé de coûts ouais
dames c'est cette attaque le plan ces
trois cas il ya deux ans protègent le
pion c3 fait un coup de défense faut
cette table basse et tranquille loin
alors pas mal parce que ce fou peuvent
jouer peut-être fois et 6 avec un stage
et devenir l' attaque du tout cette fois
c'est pas évident encore s'est pas fait
enfin g5 quand même empêche tout et
chiffons qu'a choisi ce petit rock
garry kasparov n'a pas peur pour une
raison très simple les blancs sont en
retard il a réussi à prendre
l'initiative dans l' attaque comme c'est
quand même une course au départ stéphane
les blancs attaque clairement à droite
et les noirs à gauche c'est une course
il faut donc gagner de la course et si
par son sacrifice de qualité garry
kasparov a gagné cette course puisque
maintenant les blanches au hk ils sont
encore à deux coups de la première
menace - g5 un g6 way cavaliers à 4
lyrica sport fut il ya un coût de la
première menace car il prend en échec
gagnant des races il ya tour aussi tour
contre pied ses pions c'est déjà presque
équilibré ça comment ça commence à faire
cher niveau matériel dont il faut se
méfier
en plus il a toujours des cinq à sa
disposition kasparov fou c'est un donc
la vie des sections français 3 y aura
foule et de après juste montrer quelques
coups encore pour montrer les noirs qui
se déploie kabadio 5 h 5
les blancs penser qu'ils sont sur le
point d'attaquer des 5 es là stop on
regarde le foot bessette qui devient
extrêmement fort
le fou et 7 qui ressort de sa boîte le
cavalier 5 centralisée lecavalier a
quatre qui peut prendre ces trois quand
il veut
les noirs une position d'attaquant
superbe vous pouvez regarder un peu
cette position en famille ou en
compagnie d'un partenaire échiquéen et
vous verrez que ya vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup d' attaque donc ce sacrifice en
c3 marche effectivement il faut se
donner les moyens d'arriver à le faire
donc pour ça il faut revoir le
développement de garry kasparov
après faut trois ans joue aussi ce f3 b5
donc en fait on peut tout de suite dire
que l'idée c'est de sortir des tours à
vis de stéphane si on veut trouver des
moyens de se rappeler c'est en train de
se passer puisque b5 l'idée
éventuellement jouer des cats est vendu
probablement tout bessette et donc de
libérer la classe évident pour la tour
d'amd 2 les blancs font leur truc que
les dix-sept là on peut le faire parce
qu'il n'ya pas g5 très présent se
rappeler qu'en cas de g5 en cas de g4
des blancs en 4g 4 il faut pouvoir
mettre lecavalier 6 sur la classe des cm
voilà donc si j'ai quatre
eh bien c'est ce qu'avait dit la qui va
passer d'abord grand roque fou bessette
g4 la la panacée g5 donc qu'elle ait des
six maintenant sa menace régulièrement
b4 à cause de ce coup qu'elle et ses 4
si les blanches de cavalia 2 donc on
menace de enlever ce cavalier c3 de le
rapatrier en bien où il est mal placé
dame f2 donc quasiment obligatoire
maintenant le quai c3 n'est plus défendu
mais il ya une menace était femme quel
point 6 comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
wey kaw 17 ans par la menace est ici si
les blancs font la faute de jouer roi
bien ce qu'elle fait une obsession à la
place des trois eh bien vous jouez tour
s'est vite et le sacrifice en c3 menaces
et ne peut pas être évité ouais
difficile puisqu'on a vu que sur kelly
co2 et bien le coup des 5 ou le coup
qu'elle et ses 4 vous donner une très
très belle position
voilà donc là je pense qu'on a bien vu
une fois de plus toutes les manoeuvres
des noirs qui au fond ne change pas
beaucoup
quelles que soient les coudes et blanc
puisque les planches sont toujours les
même coup les coudes attaques sont
thématiques y a pas moyen de les
améliorer
donc les planches vont dans des ordres
différents les coûts à vous de voir les
bonnes subtilité dans deux coups mais le
plan des noirs restera toujours le même
nouvelle partie stéphane la nouvelle
partie partie avant de kasparov donc là
on va voir ce qui se passe quand les
blancs ne joue pas avec grand roque donc
position c'est celle-là faux droits nous
sommes dans notre position bessengue g4
maintenant cavalier f17 on est parce qu
il faut qu'on replace nos cavaliers en b
6 et 17
et comme on l'a dit déjà plusieurs fois
c'est ce cavalier l'ad'abord sinon y'a
g5 qui pousse notre dame des deux qui
est des six ans il faut être précis
tentative de nantes dans cette position
je joue à quatre alors la a4 le problème
c'est que ça fait bill dans exactement
c'est un problème totalement
philosophique on a joué g4 d'un côté on
joue à quatre de l'autre
où est ce qu'on va rauque et voilà ce
qu'il faut se demander bon alors
évidemment à nantes c'est pas le joueur
le plus faible de la planète
il y à penser et à penser qu est ce qui
s'est dit il s'est dit voilà les doit on
pas sorti deux pièces moi j'en ai sorti
4 donc je suis mieux il faut que j'ouvre
la position ouais c'est pas grave je
vais faire le petit rock mais je vais
quand même aller taquiner le pion à 6
donc ici vous prenez en a quatre il faut
absolument pas laisser les blancs jouer
avec rock
donc si on joue b4 les blancs vont se
replacer ils vont jouer qui a aidé à
kiev 2 et ensuite ils vont peut-être
joué avec bang c'est possible donc on
ouvre les lignes 3 4 câbles hypron
cavaliers prend tout reprend mais nous
n'en sommes pas sortis aux sorties
aucune pièce n'en ont sorti aucune pièce
dans les landes a sorti 4 mais ya pas de
faiblesse par contre il ya le pion à
simon avec un peu faible pour l'instant
très bien défendu les lorrains gros
problème des blancs dans cette position
en fait c'est pas les noirs qui qui ont
fait quoi que ce soit spécial c'est une
langue qui n'ont plus d'abri pour leurs
droits
très important donc on joue faux hausse
est donc maintenant il développe
tranquillement il dit simplement ben
vas-y cherchent un abri pour ton roi
exactement moi je sais où je vais mettre
le mien je vais jouer avec petit rock
avec mes pions devant puisque tu as tour
en 4 peut pas vraiment m'attaquez
l'institut faut de petit rock petit rock
un petit rorqual à mai avec le roi un
peu à l'ère laurent un peu à l'air et
notamment garry kasparov donc qui est
très fort dans ce genre de position ici
là tout de suite penser penser au plan
d' attaque dans cette position il s'est
dit je vais jouer avec elle cinq et je
vais lui casser toutes ces cases
blanches
donc il nous faut des sept tours et
femmes
key 17 eyeless leveleux fois le pion à
fille est la seule option à 6 où ils
s'en foutent du racisme et garry
kasparov
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que sur fou
prend 1,6 il ya toujours stéphane
cavadee
il n'y a pas il n'ya pas encore quel
niveau 5 je sais qu'il ya une variante
tactique je crois qu'on peut enfin de
toute façon le roi va se retrouver très
faible le roi va se retrouver très
faibles donc vous pouvez le donner
lecture à 6 dans cette position je vois
pas d'explication rationnelle on va
regarder on va essayer de voir tout à
fait me faut pour 1,6 tout simplement de
cavaliers ces cinq mois la crise et 5 et
c'est exactement ça voilà attaque là
pour 1,4 et c'est par ce fonds prend 17
il ya tout reprend 1,4 exactement et là
le problème c'est plus fois ci c'est
attaquer une fois ci cette attaque et on
va le prendre
d'après donc il ya une fourchette en
fait moins immédiates sur vous pour 1,6
donc attendre jusqu'à et b3 clan logique
pour jouer cavalier à 5 qui va être
qu'elle foule mais c'est vrai c'est pas
mal ça t'es sport fait tour des huit
coups malin on va regarder la suite fois
cette tour ses huit cavaliers à 5 x bit
une tonne le pion à six mois mais me
garde
il joue cavalier 1,5 il donne la qualité
la non puisque là il me contre menaces
quelles épreuves trois fourchettes
attention et sur x 2 maintenant il joue
f5 et là la position blanche s'écroule
comme un château de cartes et surtout
laurent blanc
surtout le roi blanc puisqu'on voit le
cavalier à 5 hors jeu le x 7 hors jeu
les deux tours sur une colonne on sait
pas ce qu'elles font là alors que toutes
les pièces noires sont prêtes à la tâte
le kode5 il ferait vite et la tour f 2.8
qui est très fort dans son coin là bas
il comprend la grande diagonale et et on
voit en voit très bien que les plantes
peuvent pas tenir le centre là les
menaces sont très fortes
exactement exactement donc ici net
avantage pour les noirs donc vous voyez
quand les blancs ne joue pas et grand
roque
c'est ce qui a été choisi par allende
dans cette position après aussi il faut
aux 3b 5 g 4 qu'elle y avait cette dame
des deux qui avait 6 à 4 ils ne vont pas
jouer broc mais il faut absolument pas
leur en laisser l'opportunité donc tu
reprends à 4 très important on ouvre les
lignes complètement c'est le grand que
plus possible aux grandes et plus
possible et maintenant fait petit rock
nous on a une structure solide autour de
1 à 3 et il va falloir attaquer le roi
blanc ensuite à droite de l'échiquier
une petite dernière juste pour avoir une
idée supplémentaire
non c'est pas celle là où est-elle la
voilà donc c'est encore un an de
kasparov
mais une autre
son f3 aussi c'est toujours pareil faut
trois des cinq les années 2 de qui et
b17 puisque g5 de la cdg cap kébé 6 à 4
configuration légèrement différente
puisque ici kasparov a joué qui laissait
4 way donc un autre coup c'est un autre
coup c'est un autre un autre choix
c'est exactement la même position donc
effectivement cette partie ne présentent
pas l'intérêt que je pensais donc
simplement on va pas vous la montrer
puisque il faut se contenter de pions
prendra 4 qui est très bon dans cette
position donc stéphane pour résumer le
plan des noirs dans la vente principal
quand les blancs jouent avec grand roque
qui la plus dangereuse
c'est de jouer des scènes c'est de jouer
des cinq locaux libérateur de jouer tour
s'est vite éventuellement menacer tout
est hors course et 3 et à la base au
départ qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut penser à les mettre sa tour ans
évite donc jouer faux bessette est
également le remplacement de ceux des
autres cavaliers oui tout à fait
toujours cette manoeuvre cavaliers 617
et puis on a vu kasparov mettre son
cavalier à 4 pour un tacle appuyé en c3
tout à l'heure on évite des fois ça va
lancer quatre aussi il deuxième
cavaliers ans et cinq exactement donc
voilà les plans il faut très vite enlevé
le cavalier m6 ne pas le laisser sur
cette case où ils risquent de donner des
temps au blanc pour attaquer
supplémentaire donc replacements des
cavaliers le fond de cette l'atout
ensuite pour menacer de ses fils en c3
tout ça vers l'idée unique la libération
des six des 5 cette variante stéphane
c'est bon tu va la jouer puisqu'on sait
que tu vas jouer deux tournois cet été
les championnats de paris et le
championnat de france 1re es donc ça y
est la nage d'or fait partie de son
répertoire
ouais peut-être peut-être je sais tout
et ça c'est un salaire très intéressant
à louis on vous remercie d'avoir suivi
cette émission merci stéphane d'abord
nous avoir assisté lundi de trouver le
voit la prochaine fois à la prochaine
fois et donc évidemment la prochaine
fois ça sera encore la sicilienne l'âge
d'or
merci